I made this video about Not transferring
your sunscreen to a new container and it
inspired this cosmetic scientist to do
an experiment she put mineral sunscreens
in some different containers and left
them at different temperatures with
silicone this happened
interestingly the SPF actually went up
which sounds good until you remember
they started turning into rocks and as
you'd expect they don't spread very well
which is a problem because you kind of
need the sunscreen to spread and there
are changes in the metal and glass
containers too even though you would
think they'd be safer so don't transfer
your sunscreen to a new container
sunscreens often react with packaging
and that leads to lower protection